CBS News chief legal correspondent Jan
Crawford is with us now she has reported
on most of the major judicial
appointments and confirmation hearings
at the past 25 years so Jan here's a
question to you how do you think both
sides will approach the the questioning
for a doctor judge Cavanaugh and for dr.
Blasi for today well I think with the
with Ford you're gonna see a lot of
questions that kind of go to the point
of how can you be sure that this was
Brett Kavanaugh really kind of trying to
test that memory and so as a result
you're going to see questions about the
therapist remember she showed her
therapist notes to the Washington Post
did not turn them over to the committee
and said to the post that it was in
therapy she came to realize that this
was a trauma in her life that's a very
important point to make bringing a
female prosecutor to question her do you
think yes I do I mean I think that
certainly the they did not want to
repeat of what happened in 1991 with the
Thomas Hill hearings which both sides
agreed was a total disaster and could
say travesty so I think that was
designed to try to kind of get around
some of that but I think you're gonna
see questions about this therapist today
and was this a recovered memory who did
you have hypnosis I mean how did you
kind of realize that this was a
traumatic event for you after 30 years
then for Cavanaugh I think you're gonna
see questions that really kind of cover
his whole life his personal life his
behavior as a high school student did he
drink how much did he drink what were
his friends like who did he date and
then you know just this incredibly
personal questions as well about his sex
life all of which could be a very
uncomfortable and again a lot of those
kind of uncomfortable questions we saw
in 1991 - with with the Justice Thomas
all right you'll be with us all data and
all those uncomfortable questions thanks
Jen